thank you it's great to be here thanks
for inviting me and this talk is going
to be about you know these strange
creatures Nash equilibrium and these
this complexity zoo of problems and
classes like PPA D but the talk
basically or the result is another
different type of application of proof
systems here it to showing a hardness
result so in a nutshell today what we're
going to see is cryptographic hardness
or average case construction of average
case hard problems in P pad if you don't
know what peep at is don't worry I'll
tell you in a little bit in fact we're
going to show cryptographic hardness and
even in an even lower complexity class
these are complexity classes between P
and NP where we think problems are hard
but we don't know when we're looking for
cryptographic evidence for the hardness
of problems and we'll see such
cryptographic evidence today in a
nutshell what we're going to see and
this is where proof systems come in
we're going to see that so there's a
problem in these classes we're solving
it is as hard as breaking the soundness
of a particular proof system I'm
particular the proof system isn't just
any old proof system that we invented
but you know for this crowd a natural
proof system obtained by applying the
Faramir transformation to the famous
some check protocol and will define what
all of these objects are or what some of
these objects are in a little bit in the
talk but i want to start with giving you
the motivation you know what is ppad why
are we interested in cryptographic
hardness of this class I'll just mention
that previously what was known in these
terms is hardness based on
indistinguishability obfuscation
starting with a beautiful work of baton
skip on death and rose n leading up to
the work of hooba check and you give
showing hardness within these low
complexity classes
okay so the storyline today starts in
game theory and this fellow Nash who
posited or invented the notion of a Nash
equilibrium and prove that it always
exists so we have this existence proof
for a central concept in game theory the
question was the idea was that markets
reach equilibrium that's the belief in
that's the model least in economics
question is we know these equilibria
exist but is it easy to find them is it
easy to find them it's hard to find them
can we study that from a complexity
variable perspective this was the
contribution of christos papadimitriou
who embarked on kind of a systematic
study of this question and today the
story is or what we're talking about
today is how this story interfaces with
cryptography where we also need you know
a handsome representative so we have uh
fee and we're going to see how crypto
can shed light on the complexity of this
problem that has its roots in economics
or is is fundamental in economics okay
so what is a Nash equilibrium I assume
many of you have seen this so let's just
do it briefly so the idea is that we
have a game with two players both
players are deciding say this is the
famous prisoner's dilemma where the
players the red player and the blue
player can either cooperate and then
they get a certain payoff or they can
defect to the other side and then they
get these payoffs and a Nash equilibrium
is a strategy profile so a strategy for
the red player and a strategy for the
bru player such that no player on his
own can increase his payoff so it's sort
of a stable that's why it's called an
equilibrium it's a stable place to be
you know here this is a Nash equilibrium
if the red player decides to cooperate
his payoff will decrease if the blue
player decides to cooperate her payoff
will decrease the situation where both
of them are defecting is an equilibrium
and notice that it's equally briam even
though they can both do better that's
not the subject of the talk today so
that's the Nash equilibrium and his
famous theorem Nash showed that you know
this might seem like a strange state of
affairs maybe there's never such an
but in fact now showed that there's
always an equilibrium for any game that
we define an equilibrium always exists
there's always a mixed strategy so where
every player strategy is a distribution
over the possible actions and there's
always such a strategy for both players
that is an equilibrium so existence
that's beautiful and you know maybe in
the real world all of the markets and
the interactions we have converge to
such equilibria it's a very nice theory
and as a computer scientist when we
study this question it's a natural
question to ask well you know these
objects exist these like we live really
exists but how hard is it to find them
is it easy is it hard can you know is it
we assume that the market operates you
know does polynomial time computations
can it really find an equilibrium so how
hard is this problem and the first thing
we might from a pessimistic perspective
we might think is well maybe it's an
np-hard problem maybe there's just no
hope maybe there's a reduction from an
np-complete problem like three coloring
to this problem and it's just hopeless
and in fact that's unlikely to be the
case we don't believe that's the case
and this was shown by Megiddo in
Papadimitriou and basically they looked
at the you know so we have our usual
class as NP and P for decision problems
similarly when we want to compute
functions when we want to compute you
know actually you're given a game to
compute its equilibrium we're talking
about functional NP and functional p FP
n FN P so in FN P we have complete
problems like given a 3sat formula
finding a satisfying assignment if one
exists in FP we have all the functions
that are computable rather than decision
problems functions that are computable
in polynomial time and in between NPN
and FB we have this class TF NP which is
the class of NP problems where solutions
are always guaranteed to exist similarly
to the case for a Nash equilibrium Nash
showed that a Nash equilibrium always
exists for a 3sat formula it's not
always guaranteed that a satisfying
assignment exists okay so there are
problems in NP that we don't think are
in TF NP but natch is a problem in TF
and P we have this theorem proving that
for any game
that we specify there always exist a
solution and what papadimitriou and
megiddo and papadimitriou showed is that
it's unlikely that there are any np-hard
problems in T F and P particular if any
problem here is np-hard
then NP equals Co NP the polynomial
hierarchy collapses we don't believe
that's the case so we don't think this
is likely to be np-hard
computing a Nash equilibrium is unlikely
to be np-hard that's the takeaway you
can think of this GF NP by the way as
kind of a function kind of hard - it's
not it's not a precise definition but
think of it as an analogue of NP
intersect Co MP usually you discretize
and you talk about approximate
approximation up to some negligible
Epsilon
I don't know if a loan has or Walmer has
a better answer that's my answer or
anyone else once dad
well a loan is my guru pretty FMP hard
to find like this where which strategies
will this property will be supported on
so even that's a hard problem what is it
total and why does total mean there's
always a solution I'm not sure
okay so in fact you know we have this TF
NP that's a very interesting class of
problems we have Nash which is a
particular problem in TF NP but
papadimitriou didn't stop there at TF n
P he wanted to actually find sort of
more fine grained classes or a more fine
grained character characterization of
problems within TF and P in particular
he was interested in classifying these
problems by the complexity of the
argument that's used to show that a
solution always exists so here we have
Nash's proof that's a particular way of
proving that a solution always exists
and papademetriou wanted to sort of
systematically study these types of
proof and this led him to define the
class P P ad there's a subclass of TF NP
so it's a particular set of problems
within TF NP or between TF and P and F P
and the problem of finding a Nash
equilibrium is in this class and in fact
as we'll see this is sort of the right
class for studying the complexity of
finding a Nash equilibrium
and BPD the definition really is
syntactic I mean you can talk about the
argument that's used to prove totality
to prove that a solution always exists
really the way it's defined is through a
complete problem this problem called
end of the line and PPID is the class of
all problems that can be reduced in
polynomial time to the end of the line
problem that problems just given a graph
so we're given a graph with in-and-out
degrees one so every know we have nodes
in the graph every node has out degree
at most one an in degree at most one
we're given this graph we're given a
source node here in blue and the problem
is given a source node find a sink so of
course if we find a sink we know that
we've found it so it does have an NP
flavor but why is it in TF NP if you
give me a source and the graph has in an
out degree at most one and I start
walking eventually you know eventually I
have to hit a sink right the only other
option is that the whole graph is a
cycle but if the whole graph is a cycle
then I wouldn't have a source with in
degree zero so that's sort of the
intuitive argument for why a solution is
guaranteed to exist there's always a
sink in this graph and the problem is
actually finding such a sink no so any
there may be many sources and many sinks
as is the case in this problem and any
of them would be a valid solution to the
problem and that's very important so the
end or the beginning of any line is a
solution to the problem similarly with
finding a Nash equilibrium there could
be many of them and any one of them you
find as a solution to the Nash problem
so you're given one starter line and you
can find the start of a different line
and result yes
yes there's the problem clear
and the point is well if we actually
look at this graph and it's in front of
us and of course it's easy to find ass
or to find a sink given the source just
sort of walk around or do exhaustive
search but the point is that we're
interested in solving this problem on
sorry on exponential size graphs okay so
every we have a graph with two to the N
nodes every node has a label say in 0 1
to the N and the graph is implicitly
defined we're given functions for any
node for computing its successor and its
predecessor that's the input to the
problem and now given a source we have
to find a sink and the exhaustive search
solution will no longer be polynomial
time if you just start at a source and
keep going it might take you exponential
time till you find a sink the question
is whether given circuits or programs
for computing the successor and the
predecessor and given a source you can
find another another source or a sink
and now it's not clear why we would
expect this problem to be NP solvable in
polynomial time in fact I think for any
of us for the cryptographer
cryptographers who have worked with
obfuscation it seems like this should be
a hard problem
so that's the end of the line problem
it's sort of the complete problem around
which this complexity class P pad is
defined and Papadimitriou in fact showed
that Nash is in P pad problem finding a
Nash equilibrium is in P pad in a
particular there's a polynomial time
reduction given the description of a
game reducing it to an instance at the
end of the line problem so if we can
solve the end of the line problem we can
find Nash equilibria and the big open
question from 94 was whether in fact
Nash equilibria the problem finding a
Nash equilibria is complete in this
class whether there's a reduction in the
other way and this was resolved in the
beautiful work of des kolache sudol and
then Chen and Deng who showed a
reduction in the other direction so
actually finding a Nash equilibrium is
complete for this complexity class
so that brings us to the following this
view of the world we have T F and P we
have P pad within it we have the end of
the line problem we have this the Nass
problem these are polynomial time
equivalent we have other problems in P
in P P ad I think they're also complete
right brower and spend depending on how
you define them we don't have anyone and
you are oh ok so there oh they're also
complete yes
now I'm much more relaxed now I can stop
talking and just hand over the Rings
so we don't we think that Peabody is
significantly lower than TF MB we
conjecture that I don't know are the
results along these lines they're
probably black box separations but right
if P equals it yes but do we have any
results saying it's unlikely to be the
case independently of whether assuming P
is different from n P we have Oracle
separation but that's the evidence we
have okay so we have this class it has
this very nice structure these natural
problems that are complete inside it
that seems great and now the question is
well it would be wonderful if we could
have an algorithm for solving all of
these complete problems we could find
Nash equilibria in polynomial time and
solve these other problems that would be
wonderful the intuition is that maybe
it's hard it's unlikely that we're going
to get a polynomial time algorithm but
really we want evidence and the kind of
evidence we want in fact different kinds
of evidence we could talk about we could
talk about worst-case hardness of these
problems but really what we would want
is to show that there are that it's easy
to find difficult instances for these
problems that's the intuition and the
question is how to show it and that's
where crypto can come in and a central
question sense ppad was presented is
whether we can use cryptographic
assumptions so assuming problems like
factoring or discrete log or learning
with errors are hard does that imply
that ppad is hard and you know are these
problems in fact in P P ad so they go
big open question both you know for
understanding for understanding the Flex
ad class for understanding these
problems and also you know for going to
the economist and saying well here are
actual hard instances hard games where
we don't think a market can find an
equilibrium so that's the motivation
behind a talk and the result will show
is along these lines so we're going to
show a hard distribution for these
problems before going there I just want
to say a little bit since I'm talking
about TF NP and I talked about P pad and
since I have a slide courtesy the slides
are from alone and I'm sure he inherited
them from various people and the
audience so I want to say
a-and I want to motivate this I think
there are really interesting questions
here for complexity theorists for
cryptographer cryptographers for people
who study proof systems
so between TF and P and fp2 rosaria's
question we have a bunch of other
classes not just pee pad and CLS which i
talked about but other classes were
interested their natural classes we're
interested in their complexity for many
of them we know hard distributions okay
so assuming just the existence of a hard
on average problem in NP who [ __ ] have
nor and you give showed the TF and P a
hard and average distribution for TF and
P for various other classes you know
factoring for example is known to be
solvable in this class P P a
collision-resistant hash functions can
be broken in this class the evidence we
had so far for average case for hard
distributions for a way to generate hard
instances and P pad is based on
obfuscation and functional encryption in
this lower class which I'm not going to
define we had evidence also as we said
based on indistinguishability
obfuscation so these are really heavy
hammers from cryptography their big
assumptions to make and the talk today I
want to show a different cryptographic
assumption that implies hardness in
these two classes particular soundness
of a particular proof system that even
the practitioners in this audience know
something about
wait I'm confused so you're saying that
PPP any one-way permutation can be
inverted using a PPP Oracle or inverting
finding an inverse to a one-way
permutation is solvable in PPP PPP is a
much higher complexity class so it
contains ppad sorry I should have said
these are the lower the lower we go in
this beautiful drawing the lower the
complexity classes are sort of the
weaker they are the harder the hardness
or impossibility results so we don't we
don't get a one-way permutation in fact
I'm sorry we do so it's a more general
assumption I mean depending on what you
mean by factoring is hard
sorry if you can break PPA you can break
faster if you can break PPP you can
break also any other one way so you can
also break factoring here but that
doesn't follow that you can break you
know that you can solve any PPA problem
in PPP
okay so that's a it's just this is sort
of background in motivation this
beautiful drawing we're gonna for home
in I'm essentially only going to be
talking about P P ad and kind of the end
of the line problem in the talk today
you're silly
what a CLS stand for long okay
so main result that I told you about
today an efficiently sample so a
distribution that we can sample from in
polynomial time you know that's in CLS
or Peapod namely meaning we can solve it
in CLS or ppad of a problem that we can
solve in CLS or B pad and a proof that
it's hard to solve randomly sampled
instances from this distribution
assuming that a particular proof system
is sound and when I say sound I mean
that it's adaptively and unambiguously
sound and we'll talk about that what
that means much later in the talk in a
nutshell assuming soundness of a proof
system we have a hard distribution on
instances within these low complexity
classes and I just want to say a bit
more about the proof system and the Fiat
yamir transformation you're saying
so we have an efficiently sample hard
distribution we have one that's our main
result we present an efficiently sample
distribution that is hard
assuming via me
okay so let's just talk for a moment
about the fetch aamir transformation and
then I want to say a little bit more
about some corollaries of this result so
what's the proof system it's basically
the fetch aamir transformation applied
to an interactive proof system and the
pH of your transformation is a popular
heuristic from removing interaction from
cryptographic protocols so if we have
this nice protocol say between approver
and a verifier has three messages three
rounds of interaction alpha beta gamma
the only thing nicer than you know a
proof system like that is one where we
have less interaction and that's what
the Fiat Samaritans formation gives us
the idea is that the verifier sends a
very complicated hash function whatever
complicated means over to the prover and
then that's used to derive the
interaction the randomness okay so the
prover sends the original message alpha
beta is taken to be the hash of alpha
using this hash function and then the
prover also computes there at gamma and
the verifier checks that it accepts
alpha beta gamma where beta is taken to
be you know whatever alpha hash is to
under this hash function
yes the left thing is a public coin
that's important so beta is just a
random it's just public randomness
otherwise ya wouldn't be clear what to
do with this compile Thanks
so that's been hugely influential both
in terms of practice and in terms of
theory the original motivation was
transforming identification schemes into
public key signatures but since then
it's been used and studied in the
context of taking many message
interactive proofs or protocols and
converting them into two message here we
did three messages to two messages but
even if we had five or seven messages we
could just keep hashing so we always
whatever the number of messages in the
original problem protocol so long as all
the verifier is doing is sending random
coins we can always take the verifiers
message to be the hash of the transcript
up to that point
so we can reduce the interaction to two
messages no matter how many rounds we
had to begin with and the intuition is
if we think of age as a truly random
function then in fact it can be shown
that this transformation is sound the
big question or the million-dollar
question is whether it's sound in
general whether it's sound ever
and when I say is it sound I don't mean
whether you know whatever you plug in
here leads to a sound protocol but can
we design hash functions for which the
transformation is sound there does there
exist a hash function does there exist a
hash function that it for which it sound
for particular class of protocols and
that's been a big question in the
foundations of cryptography we had a
bunch of negative evidence or a bunch a
bunch of negative results for various
statements that you could for you know
various increasingly general statements
that you could hope you could hope to
make but in recent years we increasingly
have positive answers so we have
constructions of hash functions for
which it can be shown that the
transformation is secure when applied to
particular protocols to rich classes of
protocols based on different
cryptographic assumptions some of the
more standards some of them less
standard I think we'll hear more about
that certainly in Alex's talk later in
the week
and the question is or what we show is
that assuming that this transformation
is sound for a particular protocol the
sum check protocol which I won't get to
till much later in the talk so sorry
about that but it's a classic protocol
assuming the transfer there exists a
hash function for which the
transformation of that protocol is sound
then PPID is hard that's the main result
today I want to say a word about that
even we talk about these negative
results showing you know the negative
results usually what they showed is that
there exist very contrived protocols for
which there are no hash functions that
make the transformation secure but we
don't have any results showing that the
transformation as far as I know that the
transformation is insecure when apply to
a very natural protocol okay so we have
one new result we do okay but then the
hash is contrived okay so here we're
talking about whether one can you know
so for example you know take the subject
protocol that's a concrete protocol
people here have implemented it it's
running take your favorite hash function
like sha sha to 52 56 i would conjecture
that it's secure
for which we don't know how to break it
is both too complicated and the finite
functions the reason I bring it up is
that you know one of the motivations
behind this talk is we actually want to
generate games where it's hard to find a
Nash equilibrium and you know if we if
we can just take a proof system proof
system applied to a simple claim cached
with a simple hash function and use the
reduction that we'll see in the talk
today to generate simple games that are
hard to solve that would be great we're
not quite there yet but I think it's a
promising direction for research ok so
that's the main result I do want to say
that there's been this progress on
instantiating the Fiat ramier
transformation and in particular that
does give us a corollary so there are
assumptions under which we know how to
build a hash function for which a
transformation is secure and that those
assumptions would also imply that PPID
is hard so similarly we can generate a
hard distribution on instances in P P ad
assuming the optimal security of known
lwe based fully homomorphic encryption
schemes so by optimal security what I
mean is that the probability that a
quasi-polynomial time adversary given
the public key can recover the secret
key is bounded by some quasi polynomial
divided by the number of keys so that
essentially there's no super polynomial
speed up to brute-force search so a
quasi polynomial adversary can do
brute-force search and recover the key
with this probability and the assumption
is that there's no super polynomial
speed up to this attack if you can come
up with a super polynomial speed-up I
think that would be really interesting
news for the people who study lwe of
course it's not that's a strong
assumption no no so they would they
would run in less than exponential time
and totally recover the key but it's not
known how to run them in
quasi-polynomial time and succeed with
important distinction okay and we also
have this extra assumption and they
don't want to that's a much more
reasonable assumption no no no no so
just the assumption is that there's no
superpolynomial speed-up for quasi pal
oh that's so the you mean the exponent
so we assume that but it should be size
of the adversary to some constant
they're allowed to be different quasi
paulie's but they're not yeah so no no I
think we need that sorry so this is
misleading let me clarify it we assume
that there isn't a super polynomial
speed oh you assume that there exists a
constant see big said that any teatime
adversary' where T is fuzzy colleague
succeeds with probability T to the C
over two to the capital this is directly
inherited so that's a corollary through
this work with Kennedy at all where we
essentially show that under these types
of assumptions the Fiat you know the
Fiat ramier transformation is secure
when applied to interactive proof
systems or certain types of interactive
proof systems
okay so those are the two main results
and what I want to do the main thing I
want to do is talk about in the time I
have is kind of talk about the structure
of the result or how one obtains such a
result and if we have time we're sort of
will sort of delve deeper into the
subject protocol and the algebra inside
it one thing I want you know given the
theme for this week I really want to
dwell on the connection between proof
systems and its class P P ad which sort
of characterizes you think proof systems
and kind of Nash equilibria and these
two things seem to have nothing to do
with each other but in fact there's a
very Indra there's an interesting
relationship when you're trying to show
hardness results and I think this is yet
one more instance where proof systems
end up having theoretical applications
in areas where first glance they really
seem to have nothing to do with one
classical example is showing hardness of
approximation here we have a different
example for hardness on average or
hardness and P pen so first when we talk
about P pad we have this problem we're
given an exponential graph you know we
have a source and we want to find a sink
and the first question when I think
about this is a complexity theoretician
well P space problems have a similar
structure right we can think of a P
space any polynomial space computation
as being represented by a graph where
each node is sort of a configuration of
the Turing machine it's a polynomial
space Turing machine and there's an
exponential number of nodes in the graph
and what we know is we have the starting
point of the computation and we want to
find the end point of the computation it
seems very similar to the end of the
line problem the complete problem and P
P ad and you know so why can't we use P
P ad to solve you know why isn't it
obvious that this is a hard class and
the point exactly as uh as was made here
by David is that when we're solving the
end of the line program no one
guarantees you know a solution isn't
guaranteed to be the sink at the end of
the line that starts at the source that
we're given as input any source or any
sink is a valid solution to the problem
so you know we might come with our P
space computation and ask for a solution
and we're going to get some junk node
that's not on the computation
path it's not going to help us so there
are many solutions
another problem is I said that in PPID
or in the end of the line problem we
assume both that we can compute
successors and also predecessors in the
graph whereas a standard computation
only lets you compute successors but
using reversible computation on the
results of Bennett this ends up not
being a big problem the serious problem
is that there are many solutions and
some of them might be much easier to
find than the correct sink so we don't
think there's a reduction from
pspace-complete problems to PP ad and
this is where proof systems come in and
the idea is well what if we had a
computation where we also what if we
added proofs to these nodes in the graph
so what I want is for every node in the
graph on the correct path I want there
to be a proof that it's on the correct
path and any node in the graph that
doesn't have a correct proof becomes a
self-loop if I had such proofs then now
I can build a graph where there are no
sinks except the correct sink and now if
you want to find if you want to solve
the end of the line problem and I give
you this source you either have to cheat
the proof system we find some node
that's not on the correct path but
somehow you know find an accepting proof
for it so that it's not a self loop
because self loops are not valid
solution or you have to find the actual
solution and that's going to be hard
because it's a P space complete problem
you're not going to be or it's a hard
problem you're not going to be able to
do that so you have to cheat the proof
system and you know so basically we can
use computationally sound proof systems
and what we're going to say is that
solving the end of the line requires
either breaking the proof system or
solving this expensive computation
so that's kind of the that's where proof
systems come in and are really helpful
for building hard instances for Pete bad
problems that clear it's a good point
it's a good time for a question it's not
clear why Fiat Shamir matters phrase
like yes dear it doesn't matter so this
is a general connection proof systems
are helpful for pped and I'll attribute
this to valiant I don't know that it
appeared explicitly but this was Paul
valiance suggestion
yes so you repeat the question so the
the the instance but the question was
what was the instance that were sampling
and the instance is an instance for the
original computation this thing we're
finding you know the correct thing the
correct end of the path is hard so I
assume that sort of hard on average and
I sample an instance for that and then I
also sample I guess public parameters
for a proof system and now nodes every
node on the graph contains a state and
also a proof that that state is the
correct state along with that and
finding a solution is either finding a
cheating proof or finding the correct
source so that all sounds great it's not
as easy as it sounds and it actually
gets quite hairy there's a reason we
haven't had this is the paradigm
proposed by Paul valiant in 2004 and we
haven't really been able to instantiate
it since then and the reason is that we
need really powerful proof systems so
one thing we need is we need to be able
to move along this graph remember we
need to be able to compute the successor
to any node and that means we need the
proof to be incremental so given a
correct proof for this state we need to
be able to hop along to the next state
in the computation and in polynomial
time quickly generate a proof for the
next state along the computation that's
known as an incremental e verifiable
proof system it's not clear I mean that
seems like a helpful object and we're
going to talk about it in a minute but
just any old proof system you pull out
of a box including Fiat Amir is not
going to have that property a second
subtle point is that we also want
unambiguous proofs to keep this nice
structure I want there to be a unique
correct proof for every node along the
path I don't want to start having
multiple nodes along the path because I
want to keep the in-degree and
out-degree
to be at most one so we need what are
known as unambiguous proofs for every
correct state along the path there's a
unique accepting proof and it's hard to
find you know maybe there are other
accepting proofs but it would be it's
hard to find them
the problem is a tubers are two
different edges yeah two poops give you
two different nodes and now I don't know
how the graph starts looking and I'm
worried yeah yeah it's Valley
introduction but yes it works with any
such group system to make you buy this
building yes the main contribution is
building such a proof system for a hard
problem
so even though it only gives you one
message to actually sort of in its head
sort of step through this sort of
attractive process so you know again
even though the Cooper is sort of doing
things at one shot then you have a way
to sort of verify that sort of goes
through specific steps that are
indicated by the interactive proof that
you were being professing so you're
talking about the unambiguous property
you know it's not not very accurate but
but it does sort of have to be put sort
of describe it as having the flavor and
sort of forcing approver to go through
like a sequence of to do you know
pre-designed steps in order yeah it's
not clear to me but it's I mean it's I
think it's a nice so here's a suggestion
for a it's not an open problem session
but find properties of the original
proof system that guarantee that ones of
you apply the pH Amir to it you get an
incremental proof system and I will try
to abstract that I know it's not going
to work I think for any proof system you
start with but maybe find some
properties
no but I don't know how to make this yes
I don't know how to make that you mean
this is a very intuitive statement but I
don't know I mean I have to go like this
to sort of back it up okay good so kind
of that's the template and really what
we want we definitely care about it and
that's what we that's why we say that
solving this graph requires either
solving the original problem or finding
a cheating proof and assuming that the
proof system is computationally sound
finding a cheating proof is hard and so
you know solving this problem will be
hard so we're just going to show ya so
I'm not interested what I want to show
is that the adversary can't succeed with
high probability
so maybe with if he succeeds with
negligible probability that's fine as
always when we talk about kind of hard
problems we allow a negligible success
product alone
okay so I want to dwell basically as if
stuff was saying the main really what
we're talking about here is finding a
hard computation where we are able to
sort of have these incremental proofs
and you know that's interesting for
showing hardness a feedback but I think
it's a natural and interesting notion in
its own right
it's incrementally verifiable
computation where what we're looking for
what we would like is given a long
computation we want to be able to
perform it via a sequence of small steps
polynomial time or maybe even linear
time steps where after every step we end
up with the state so after the ice step
we end up with the state Sigma I so we
have this step or successor function s
and we have a verification so this state
includes kind of the state of the
computation and also a proof and the
verification given you know I in a
claimed state can accept or reject and
what we want completeness means that you
know if we run this step function really
L times we'll get the correct output but
we want that at every step along the way
we can also verify that we're at the
right location even before we reach the
end of the computation okay so it's hard
to find any any state Sigma Sigma I that
will make the verify or accept that's
not the correct one that's the notion of
an incremental verifiable competition
especially I think for the workshop this
week is a natural notion to sort of
dwell on we have some examples along
these lines I'll talk about it at the
end we have very few and I think it's a
nice challenge for this community to
come up with more the point for the talk
today and the connection to PPID is that
an incremental verifiable computation
procedure for any hard on average
problem using the reduction we just saw
immediately gives a heart on average
distribution in P P ad also in CLS
yes I need an ambiguity thanks is this
requirement of an ambiguity what
basically people to just take any like
start and customer that you see yes but
it's not an ambiguous so I see so if
there were some power some generic
techniques that will give you snacks
that are welcome biggest and potentially
one could a sort of relax the assumption
to just existence or some as opposed to
talking about the particular subject
yeah
okay so I want to talk a little bit
about how we what we actually do is we
build an incrementally verifiable
computation for a particular problem and
that problem is sharp set the sharp
counting set problem given a set formula
on n variables counting the number of
satisfying assignments okay so that's
certainly np-hard in fact it's in you
know sharped P so it's a sharp P
complete problem we believe that it's
hard we know that it's we have a worst
case to average case reduction from it
so we also know how to sample average
case hard instances for which it's hard
to count the number of satisfying
assignments and what the main
contribution are what we do is we build
an incremental a verifiable counter for
this problem okay so the way it looks is
you know we have along the way we have
these nodes what we want is something
along the line where in every node along
the way not quite what we get but it's
close to it so at every node along the
way we have we know the number of
satisfying assignments up to that node
okay so in the ithe node we have the
number of satisfying assignments between
0 to the N and I where I is a number
between 0 and 2 to the n to the N minus
1 and we have a proof that Y I is
correct that's a correct number of
satisfying assignments that's the goal
or that would be what's we would want an
incremental e-verify abow computation
procedure that just goes along and
computes in the end the correct number
of satisfying assignments for the
formula and also gives us the proof that
that's the correct number and if we can
build such a thing then we know that P P
ad is hard
good condition so how would we go about
building such a thing or what are the
challenges so first we want polynomial
size proofs so I want a proof here that
why I is the correct number of accepting
assignments within the first iPod within
the first by assignments okay so we want
a polynomial size proofs because we want
each node to have a polynomial size
label and for that we can use the famous
some check protocol of Elune ford no
Karloff any son that's exactly why it
was proposed it's an interactive
protocol for proving that the number of
satisfying assignments to a formula
either within a range or within all the
possible assignments equals some value Y
but that's an interactive protocol hey
whereas here we have no interaction we
just want to proof a non interactive
proof and that's where we use the Fiats
Amir transform okay so using the fetch
Amir transform on the subject protocol
gives us these non interactive proofs
that are verifiable in polynomial time
showing that the number of satisfying
assignments really is the claimed why
good because you need I'm trying I'm
giving myself decided you need proof
they gives you a short proof for a big
problem and that's where the some
progress but I think that in general I
think of proof systems as in general
giving a you know proof system is
interesting if it gives a short proof
for a complex problem I would say any
proof system that's interesting you
could plug in here right and I think the
main some check and fetch Amir are
really important so fetch Amir is a way
to make things on interactive that does
seem inherent but also we have this we
want this incremental thing right we
want it to be incremental II updatable
and that I have no idea how to do for
general proof systems but particularly
for the subject you know with the future
me replied to the some check we know how
to do that to get the incremental proof
update that's the main challenge
an ambiguity basically an ambiguity
means that there's a so first it says
there's a correct proof for any step and
the second thing is that it's hard to
find even for a correct state it's hard
to find any accepting proof that's not
the correct one the prescribed one
okay so our main challenge is how in the
world do we go from a proof that you
know within the first ice to assignments
there are why I accepting a statements
to prove that within the oh this should
be I plus one that it within the first I
plus one statements the number of
satisfying assignments is something
that's a challenge and how do we do it
so the approach there were the way we're
going to do it is recursive and you know
so long as you don't care about bounding
your proof size it's it's very easy so
let's see the naive approach anyway so
suppose we have a counter an incremental
verifiable counting procedure for
formulas on J variables okay so finding
the number of satisfying assignments on
J variables it's sort of a problem whose
complexity is size 2 to the J and I want
recursively to find from such a counter
a counter for counting the number of
satisfying assignments on J plus 1
variables that's going to be the
approach that seems a you know we like
recursion that's nice so suppose we have
such a thing for instances of length 2
to the J this is this LJ this is the
length of the path of the incremental EE
verifiable computation you know it steps
LJ steps and it arrives at the correct
solution and a proof for that solution
yeah
there's two different flies yes oh yeah
these are two different flies
so this is the Phi this is a five that
has J variables and this is a formula
that has J plus 1 variables so I want to
using a counter that can count for
formulas with J variables
I want to recursively build a counter
for J plus 1 variables a hardware
problem
good and I just want to say that I don't
assume here the length can be I don't
really care how this was done maybe it's
a path of length larger than two to the
J maybe there were some auxilary steps
here in the middle I don't care what I
care about is that in the end of the day
there were LJ steps taken to do counting
for J variables and there's some proof
in the end there's a convincing proof
maybe it has many some check proofs
inside it many just maybe it just has
one maybe it's I don't care what the
format of it is it's something it's an
except it's a convincing proof for J
variables hey so now what I want to do
is I want to do J plus 1 variables and
the natural solution is well let's first
count all of the assignments that end
with 0 the number of accepting
assignments at end with 0 and then let's
count the accepting assignments at end
with 1 and the sum of these two counts
is the number of accepting assignments
write every assignment either ends with
a 0 or ends with a 1 so that seems great
I can just do this counting and then I
can do this counting but it's not as
simple as it looks and the point is that
I can't forget while I'm counting over
here the assignments on the right side
if we think about this as a recursion
while I'm counting on the right side I
can't forget the answer for the
solutions at end with 0 and I can't
forget the proof so I have to keep that
in my memory if I want it to be
incrementally incrementally verifiable
so that in the end I can actually
compute the sum the correct number of
the sum of these two values and the
proof of this sum is going to be having
it embedded the proof for the first half
and the proof for the second half
concatenated and then it's verifiable
anyone can go and verify that in the
left side sort of by recursively in the
left side there were really this number
of satisfying assignments on the right
side there were this number of
satisfying assignments and we are
convinced
the problem is that winding this
recursion well the number of steps we
took is fine right we just sort of
doubled
you know we doubled the size of the
computation and we doubled the number of
steps we took so that's fine that seems
fair the problem is that we also doubled
the proof size in the end so if we do
this in the end we're going to end up
with an exponential proof size that's no
good we want to end up with polynomial
proofs so this is a problem it was also
a problem that Valiants thought about
when we was thinking about these things
and his solution was to say well let's
take these proofs and merge them so
let's take these two proofs and add an
extra node that sort of merges them
together into a new proof that proves
the sum and then we'll be okay
then we've sort of shrunk the proof back
down to size and we can move on in the
recursion nothing is going to explode
exponentially so that's great if you can
do it if you can merge in polynomial
time that really does work out very
nicely the problem is that this is hard
to do it requires super extractable
snarks and Paul volumes work it's hard
to see how to do it or I don't know how
to do it with an unambiguous proof
system so it seems sort of inherent to
these super extractable starts that use
CS proofs ambiguities seems inherent so
it's not clear how to use this idea it's
nice if you just want to do incremental
e verifiable computation as an
application but if you wanted to prove
to use it in order to get an ambiguous
proofs and show hardness of P pad it's
not clear what to do
so the new idea or the way we take it on
is you know we do this recursion we do
the left half and we do the right half
and we end up with these two proofs and
we'll merge them
when did this merge doesn't have to be
sort of a caught a single step maybe it
can be a long computation so long as the
merge itself is incrementally verifiable
so we're not going to merge this in one
step instead we're going to take a
possibly long path maybe it's you know a
constant even a car you know a constant
number of times maybe it's a hundred
times the length of the left side and
the right side we don't care so long as
this path in itself is incrementally
verifiable this merge itself is
incrementally verifiable right we want
everything to be incrementally
verifiable so even in some intermediate
node here along the merge computation I
have to know that I'm in the right place
and I'm doing the right thing and then
in the end we'll end up with one merged
proof and then we're good to go we've
shrunk the proof size down and nothing
explodes so that's the idea of course
the question is how can you do it but on
a conceptual level one new idea is that
rather than merging in one step you can
take a lot of time to merge not too long
but a long time so long as your merge
itself is incrementally verifiable so I
think about it as a constant number of
times times the pet the length of sort
of the counter for J variables so we
have an exponential number of steps here
each of them is polynomial and each of
them once you get to it you can verify
anyone can verify that you're in the
right place we're allowing them where to
take a really long time and that's sort
of key and that's exactly we're going
back to this weakest point since I'm not
going to have time to show that I can do
it maybe maybe we'll end and everyone
can go get some wine in the reception
and then we can come back and do kind of
the algebra of the sum check and show
how we do it but that is where we really
really use this
chair of the Fiat Shamir transformation
and the structure in particular of the
some Czech protocol in order to merge
some Czech proofs so I have this
dramatic slide but I think we're not
going to go into the belly of the beast
[Music]
consents the disappointment ok so let me
summarize and then maybe we can discuss
we had good discussion during the talk
but we can discuss some more so summary
there's this rich complexity zu between
n P and P you know we as cryptographers
are used to thinking about the
cryptographic problems between P and NP
we know classes like SDK mystical zero
knowledge you know the intersection of
NP & Co and P but there's a whole other
rich complexity zoo that some
cryptographers have been working and
making very beautiful progress on but I
think there are a lot of open questions
and directions to pursue by taking the
cryptographic lense to explore in
complexity here we have this notion of
incrementally verifiable computation
that I think is really interesting in
its own right and once we have add the
unambiguous property leads us to hard
problems in P P ad and we instantiated
this sort of general connection
specifically using the fetch I'm here
for subject to get an incremental
verifiable counter for counting set some
open problems so just this notion of
incrementally verifiable computation
more schemes for more computations I
just think it's a nice problem that is
under explored we have some upcoming
work on that with all my planet and
money nor I'm interpretive the citation
but forgot this question of
instantiating the fetch I'm here for
some check and other protocols Alex
we'll talk about it I think it's a
fantastic open problem maybe it can lead
to hardness or to showing that you know
something like the lwe problem is in P P
ad or factoring is in P P ad and there's
a couple of recent works replacing the
sharp set problem with a repeated
squaring problem that's related to the
hardness of factoring
and I think finally sampling small hard
instances of gnash actually being able
to sample these games there are a couple
of bottlenecks there's a question of the
reduction from the end of the line
problem back to the nash equilibrium
problem there's some work on that in the
game theory community and from our side
coming up with these very succinct small
instances at the end of the nice
instances at the end of the line problem
is a nice is a nice direction and I will
end there thank you
[Applause]
because it depends on what's happening
in yeah I think a lot of what this
research research is about getting more
concrete evidence for harnessing nothin
maybe for you know practically heuristic
ly understanding the security of snacks
then we're okay with knowledge
assumptions everything with HIV very six
but here it's not clear that I mean it's
not so give you may be an alternative
assumption but maybe not a good
assumption
conversely this [ __ ] poverty line so
it's inherited under adoption right
one could think of I think that's a
great open open problem is an ambiguity
seems sort of important if you want to
make so let me go back to that picture
right so we use a proof system to sort
of make all of these guys self loops and
keep the original line as a particular
is just a line and that's where we
needed the unambiguous and I don't know
I mean I think it's very interesting to
ask if you don't have an ambiguity but
you do have a proof system that's
incrementally verifiable you end up with
all of these extra nodes along the path
and you somehow need to manage things so
that there are no collisions it's not
clear that you can't in particular if
there are sort of two proofs for every
statement but the two proofs are
unrelated and they just formed two lines
here then you're fine the problem is
what happens if things start colliding
and diverging and how do you control the
structure but I think it's a good open
problem I don't I'm not pessimistic
about it then you have a concrete you'll
have very easy nodes very easy sings in
any such graph no matter what problem
you circle it depends all I want to say
is that it depends on the proof system
right if the proof system somehow if the
if it's ambiguous but it sort of just
generates with the successor and the
predecessor it generates two separate
lines then I think you might then once
you go through these two parallel lines
then the reversible computation
reduction will make a graph it's
completely good school sinks so don't
disagree with you I'm just saying that
the fact that a proof system is
ambiguous doesn't on its own mean that
this reduction fails there might be an
ambiguous proof system where you can
make it work
so are there any more instances where we
use down ambiguity OOP systems good yeah
so in particular Ron and I have some you
know so we use it for batch fear it's
very helpful for batch verification so
the property if you have a proof system
and interactive proof system that's
unambiguous even a non interactive one
and that's very helpful for batching
many verifications kind of verifying
case statements at much less than K
overhead and I don't know that's one
very nice use of it yeah Onis I think
maybe you could get something like that
also for for computational just for
computational we already know that's
verification results then go in other
directions and I don't know other
applications for an ambiguity there
might be once
it's an open problem slide we talked
about the hmm for the subject apart but
like you have to define exactly what you
mean so there's an issue of the running
time of the honest poober and in these
results we have for instantiate in the
Fiat Shamir the running time of the
honest poober in the protocol plays an
important role and you can think of
various ways around it I'm interested in
instantiating it for subjects of
polynomial size and I assume that
through some complexity leveraging that
will give a result for PPID but you
could also think of instantiating it for
other problems where maybe they're using
a trapdoor the computation of the
proofer can be made more efficient
there's a nice direction to go in the
hard instance we build the honest proved
er is running in quasi-public time and
but you know the proof system is sound
until much struttin against much
stronger poopers there's some complexity
leveraging going on
it's like every year like
but you're not actually working I mean
the not oh yeah so the question was that
were not actually sort of we have this
long merge procedure in every step along
the way is polynomial but we're not
actually merging two useful computations
efficiently and that's right we're not
merging them efficiently we're taking a
long detour to merge them and in
particular what this means is that we
end up we just think about this as an
incremental you verifiable computation
scheme it has a big overhead right there
are many steps along the incremental
verifiable computations that don't
really correspond to helpful steps along
the original computation so it's a big
detour you're taking in order to get
this purify ability along the way
there's no more questions let's take a
guy again for the reception right